معنى منا منا اللواء فايز الدويري الخبير
العسكري والاستراتيجيه اللي هو فايز
الرئيس الاوكراني يهنئ جهاز الاستخبارات
استخبارات بلاده بالنجاح في استهداف
الداخل والعمق الروسي هل يمكن القول بانما
هددت به اوكرانيا تنفذه الان
نعم هي بصوره جزئيه وان كانت محدوده لكنها
بدات تهاجم اهدافا ملتقى
البدء من جسر كرش في المره الاولى والمره
الثانيه
الوصول الى الكرملين
مهاجمه المبنى الذي يرتبط مباشره بوزاره
الدفاع والامن السيبراني قبل ذلك تدمير
الطراد موسكافا والان غورنياك وبالتالي
هناك اهداف منتقى يبدو يتم التحضير لها
والتخطيط بدقه متناهيه
وتستطيع ان تحقق انجازات وان كانت متباعده
ولكنها تهاجم اهدافا يمكن وضعها ضمن
السياق الاستراتيجي وبالتالي كانه بدا
يحقق ما وعد به لا اقول يحقق كل ما وعد به
ولكنه بدا يحقق بدايات ما ودعت به وهذا
ايضا ما يصرح به المسؤلون المسؤولون
العسكريون الاوكرانيون عندما يتحدثون عن
رمزيه الاهداف ولكن ما الذي يعكسه ذلك على
صعيد الجانب الروسي فيما يتعلق بقدرته على
صد هكذا هجمات
اولا الامن المطلق غير موجود
في اي حرب عبره تاريخ لا وجود للامن
المطلق وبالتالي لا يمكن من حدوث من حصول
اختراقات في الجدار الامني الان المسيرات
لا يمكن لروسيا ان تنجح بالدرجه المطلقه
في اسقاط كافه الطائرات قد تسقط عشرات
الطائرات لكن لابد ان تنجح بعض الطائرات
في الوصول فكذلك فيما يتعلق بالزوارق
البحريه الان ثم تدمير اكثر من زورق بحري
ولكن استنادا الى الروايه الاوكرانيه نجح
هذا الزورق ولسوء الحظ نجح في المكان
الخطا
واستغرق كانت في الجدار الاهم حيث يتم
مهاجمه سفينه الانزال
غورياك وهي تعتبر الافضل والذي هي القدره
على عمليات الانزال والابرار للمشاه
والمشاه الاليه
والدبابات
ما تفسير ان الجانب الاوكراني لا يتبنى
بشكل مباشر وصريع وعلى لي هذه العمليات
النوعيه في العمق الروسي
هو بدا بدا تدريجيا وبصوره متصاعده في
المره الاولى جسر كيرش كان هناك نفي وثبت
لاحقا انه تم تدميره بواسطه شاحنه
والاستخبارات الروسيه حددت المسار العام
لها حتى لحظه التفجير وكان هناك اهمال من
الاشخاص المعنيين بالتفتيش على مدخل الجسر
في المره الثانيه التلميحات كانت اكثر
وضوحا واكثر صراحه وبالتالي الان عندما
يهنئ عندما يهنئ الرئيس زيلينسكي
المسؤولين بنقل المعركه الى العمق الروسي
وللاراضي المعتدي الجانب المعتدي فهو
اقرار بصوره واضحه وهناك اشارات انه تم
استهداف كورنياك وتم اخراجها عن العمل اذا
هناك اعتراف في البدايه لم يكن لكن حتى
هذه الاعتراء اللحظه الاعترا ف ياتي ضمن
القدرات الاوكرانيه الخالصه لا تستخدم حتى
هذه اللحظه المساعدات الغربيه في استهداف
الداخل الروسي من ضمن الاهداف البارزه
اليوم ايضا هو ميناء نوفرسيس ولكن اريد ان
نربط الان بين من ناحيه استراتيجيه بين
هذه الاستهدافات النوعيه وبين ما يجري في
الميدان داخل اوكرانيا من هجوم بومداد
وعمليات قتاليه ايضا
الان خلال الثلاث اسابيع الماضيه لا يوجد
معارك حاسمه على الارض من كلا الجانبين
ولا يوجد انجازات يعتد بها قد تكون
انجازات تكتيكيه لكنها لا ترقى الى
المستوى العمليات الذي يسمح سواء للجانب
الروسي بقلب الصفحه والتحول من الدفاع الى
الهجوم باستثناء محاولاته في منطقه خركيف
ولمان او الجانب الاوكراني للزج باحتياطي
الذي يقول لم استخدمه بعد اذا هي انجازات
على المستوى التكتيك المتواضع
وبالتالي بدات الجانب الاوكراني تحديدا
يحاول ان يديم ما يقول انه صاحب اليد
العليا وان لديه الهيمنه من خلال
الاحداث التي يقوم بها سواء بالطائرات
المسيره او بالجوارق المسيره
نعم انا فايزه دويريا الخبير العسكريه
والاستراتيجي شكرا جزيلا لك